you're going to be absolutely disgusted  after you hear how evil this country is  this country hired millions of desperate  poor people from South Asia locked them  into Ironclad contracts took away their  passports upon arrival so they couldn't  escape craned them into filthy crowded  dorms and then they warped them to the  Bone for next to nothing they will work  18-hour days in 122 degree heat to build  everything from stadiums to hotels and  more since 2013 almost 12 slaves I mean  workers die every single week this  wealthy country love slave labor so much  that nearly 90 of its entire population  is made up of these slaves and this evil  country is Qatar home of the 2022 World  Cup which is why